uh ben i drove two hours all the way
from pasadena well thank you i
appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
my biggest current concern is we as
conservatives do
the most horrific job at uh reaching out
to the black community it's like
and i mean you know it's not only on us
but it's the fact that it's like
when we get called racist we say well
our fiscal policy is
very yeah exactly it's like it's like
it's like exactly right it's like
instead of calling somebody an
for
calling you racist white supremacist you
know whatever um you're speaking that
language
so how do we combat that by calling them
an i mean like really that's
that is the actual answer if someone
calls you a racist without evidence this
makes them technically
in the dictionary parliament's an
like it really that and it's not
appropriate to have a conversation if
someone calls you a racist with no
evidence
your proper response should not be well
that's reasonable let's have a
conversation about this
because once you do that you've
acknowledged that a reasonable person
might think you're a racist which means
you're a racist right in the minds of
the public
so you actually have to you actually
have to create a basic mutual assured
destruction which is they call you a
racist you say no
you're just you're just a jerk right and
and then
do you want to actually have a
conversation about policy or you want to
name throw because i think you're ugly
also
so how do we how do we reach out to the
black community so i mean i
i think i think the way to reach out to
the black community is the same way that
you reach out to everybody which is
telling them the truth i think the
message to the black community
should be listen america is not going to
get in your way and as i said before we
will stand with you every step of the
way if someone is trying to get in your
way but you have to show me the person
trying to get in your way
i think that we should be doing a better
job as conservatives going into
sit into inner cities and saying to kids
here is a
like i want i actually would like to do
this go into inner cities and set up a
scholarship fund and say if you get
these grades we will pay for your
college
and major companies should do this they
should say we'll pay for your college
you work for the company for four years
and so the job is guaranteed coming out
but a social structure has to be
achieved and sometimes that has to be
done artificially
because right now the biggest problem in
a lot of black communities that there's
no real social structure
as far as a two-parent family where
they're telling the kids go to school
get an education and you'll succeed in
america
right now well over 70 percent of black
kids are born out of wedlock
very difficult to have a very successful
social structure when a lot of the guys
that you know have abandoned their kids
or in prison
and that's an individual decision by a
lot of bad people making a lot of bad
decisions so
you know i think that the the best thing
that we as conservatives can do is not
lecture to the black community
about you know all the things that the
black community does wrong but we can
say
is look we can all sit here bitching and
moaning about how the united states is a
terrible place
and the democrats will be happy to do
that with you all day they will they'll
be happy to sit here and and moan
and then go to washington dc and do
nothing for you
nothing for you but if you actually want
to succeed here's how we're going to
succeed
we're going to sit down right now and
i'm going to make with you right now
individually
a success plan for you and if you stick
with this plan every step of the way
i guarantee you that by the time you're
25 years old you won't be living
in a hovel you're going to be living in
a nice apartment in a decent area with a
job
i guarantee you that's what's going to
happen it has to be done not on a
governmental level
on an individual level because here's
the thing we're all either dependent on
government or we're dependent on
capitalism
and so we have to make people dependent
on capitalism again we have to make
people dependent on markets again and on
freedom again and not on government
again
can i shake your hand absolutely